chantiers chibougamau a annoncé la
relance de l'ancienne usine de domtar à
lebel sur quévillon aujourd'hui 14 ans
après sa fermeture
on en parle avec frédéric verreault
directeur exécutif du développement
corporatif de chantiers chibougamau qui
arrive tout juste qu'ils descendent
l'appareil de l'avion bonsoir son jus
clients alors vous avez dit aujourd'hui
d'un point de presse ou en tout cas la
direction a dit que le point tournant
dans ce qui s'est passé c'est françois
legault c'est françois legault qui a
vraiment faire en sorte que ce projet la
crise fonctionnent avec le projet il
était sur les rails mais le projet comme
celui là à concevoir à définir à
structure et à financer
c'est pas une mince affaire c'est
surtout pas un long fleuve tranquille et
à six jours du vote en 2018 monsieur
legault était passé par le jeune de
chibougamau et nonobstant les voir qu'il
fallait qu'il additionne il avait pris
un temps on était cinq je crois dans la
salle de rencontre avec sa famille lui
et udinese
voilà ce que je propose pour le québec
puis son pitch politique saison je vais
vous ne parlez de quoi vous avez besoin
pour que ce projet là fonctionne et à la
fin je l'avais dit qui sait peut-être
allons-nous faire de grandes annonces
ensemble et c'est ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui aide financière de 138
millions sur un projet de 342 millions
donc votre pitcho fonctionner à monsieur
le groupe a fait ce cadeau financier là
il était établi avant l'arrivée de
monsieur legault et sa porte a précisé
qu'il ya deux volets à l'intervention
financière
d'une part il ya environ 120 millions $
qui sont prêtées qu'on remboursera au
bout de dix ans ayant notre parti qui
fait que le gouvernement du québec de
vie actionnant d'un partenaire donc si
l'usm va bien si elle génère des profits
les québécois vont en tirer des
dividendes et on a beaucoup
d'indicateurs de marché qui suggère qui
résulte en général dans les dernières
années cela dit les indicateurs de
marché pour le prix de la pâte le prix
du bois
on a même parlé d'une crise sur les
copeaux comment va le marché
présentement c'est un marché qui est de
plus en plus fragmenté avec les
différentes catégories de poids zouia
pas ces deux contextes où tous les
produits sont au vert simultanément et
c'est là où une entreprise comme la
nôtre actif dans les produits de
construction en bois destinés à de
grands bâtiments en bois massif
la structure à la construction de
maisons neuves
le bois d'oeuvre les copeaux est
maintenant là par kraft cette
diversification avec nos yeux répartis
dans plusieurs familles nous assurer un
équilibre
par exemple si la construction
résidentielle est en baisse aux etats
unis les investisseurs
et là c'est notre gros bois qui va être
consommés mais la pâte kraft un peu
nouveau pour vous absolument c'est un
nouveau métier qu'on apprend je voulais
prendre les copeaux pour sa pourrais tu
pour être capable de générer de
fabriquer cette pâte plus résistantes au
jour où vous développiez génique
notamment absolument d'un court point de
départ de ce projet c'est la
problématique récurrente de copeaux
depuis 10 20 30 40 ans est cyclique où
on est là où comme entreprises dans nos
produits de construction
on voit bien on a un bandeau qui nous
porte mais les copeaux momentanément
viennent nous freiner avec le doute de
notre capacité à les ventes et du prix
auquel on les vendre donc partant de là
on s'est intéressé à la pâte kraft de
simultanément est aussi un marché
mondial de la pâte kraft qui craint un
essor extraordinaire
la fidh de pâte kraft qui fait avec les
ressources québécoises et les reconnaît
l'échelle mondiale pour sa résistance il
y en a pas eu
ailleurs sur la planète qui est aussi
résistante et ça veut dire quoi dans le
concret s'avérait que du papier dessus
du papier toilette on le souhaite soit
yeux on soit résistant et il y aurait
comme la pâte kraft issus de la forêt
boréale québécoise pour procurer ces
attributs au papier toilette alors il ya
ça avec l'urbanisation en chine et en
inde
de plus en plus de gens hors des
toilettes évidemment oui qui stimule la
demande et il faut jamais oublier que la
fibre de voile et renouvelables et
compostables alors pour des emballages
alimentaires verres à café boîte d'un
big mac dans un restaurant de
restauration rapide tout ça requiert
davantage de bois alors ces éléments qui
font que les indicateurs
macroéconomiques de marché sont tous au
vert pour des perspectives de croissance
sur 20 ans ce sont quand même des
exemples bien concrets de bien compris à
quoi à quoi ça sert qui va acheter votre
pâte kraft
c'est un beau problème à gérer on va
fabriquer trois cent mille tonnes et on
a déjà avant même d'avoir officialisé
aujourd'hui reçu des offres de contrats
pour 700 mille tonnes en plus du double
de ce qu'on va fabriquer nous ont été
proposés par des clients des offres de
contrats fermes alors on est à
à composer avec des demandes
essentiellement du marché chinois mais
aussi des fabricants de papier dessus
québécois qui ont des besoins à combler
et surtout on n'a qu'à vide on va
s'ajouter aux marchés dans la mesure où
les autres joueurs de par kraft ont
gardé leur marché la croissance mondiale
de 300 à 600 mille tonnes 18 par année
et on va proposer la moitié l'année
prochaine donc il va travailler chez
vous est ce que les anciens travailleurs
de la domtar seront réembauchés pour ce
pour ceux qui veulent ou qu'ils peuvent
on est déjà ça 80 personnes qui sont
confirmées pour leur reprise la pression
et 150 qui sont au travail aujourd'hui
sont des gens qui viennent des quatre
coins du québec mais dont le noyau est
effectivement originaire de lebel sur
quévillon déjà qu'ils ont eux-mêmes ou
dont les pères les mères ont travaillé à
une ancienne époque qui viennent
aujourd'hui partager le projet mais déjà
québec jean du grand montréal alors
c'est vraiment de partout que convergent
vers la belle sur kevin chantiers
chibougamau a été créée en 1961 par le
lucien filion aucun lien de famille du
ciel fillion que toujours vivants qui
étaient là aujourd'hui le présentateur
est seule elle pour ce qui est
exactement moi j'en ai 2 et michel
fillion qui le chef de direction ne veut
pas qu'ils parlaient avec émotion 1 61e
mon père
enfin je suis mauvais sensible quand je
parle de 25 minutes
il
il est monsieur de suspense ou moins
[Applaudissements]
alors pourquoi cette émotion qu est-ce
qui qu'est ce qu'elle nomme monsieur
fillion je vous rassure je dis pas
reprendre chez lui oui alors ça aura bel
et bien une moto a quelquefois du rhin
durant cette grève c'est vraiment les
douze travaux d'astérix a relancé une
usine fermée depuis 14 ans comme celle
là alors il ya la charge de travail et
la fatigue il avait bon c'est un jalon
crise et que c'est pas la destination
c'est une étape que l'on franchit
aujourd'hui
alors il y aura plus de recul qui est
pris plus on paye sur pause pendant
quelques heures on met de côté les
dossiers mais c'est une aventure qui lui
même chanson figaro qui est familiale et
nous quatre on va travailler le matin on
se pose pas 5 en 10 questions pourquoi
on veut leur ont volé pour développer
une entreprise qui va être plus
résilient plus solide pour la génération
dit filion qui poussent pour les enfants
de michel de ses phrases de ses soeurs
qui étaient tous leurs collègues guy
jason terry o'neill et combien on est
comme ça alors équipés eux alors c'est
ce qui donne la vérité bonrepaux bonne
fin de semaine
merci beaucoup monsieur rero merci bien